most Americans have probably never
tasted real extra virgin olive oil you
go to the grocery store and you see all
of these bottles of olive oil and they
all say Extra Virgin Olive Oil from
Italy and they have like a photo of like
a humble farmer picking his olives
that's like mostly a lie the fact is
that extra virgin olive oil the real
stuff the stuff that the people in the
Mediterranean have been consuming for
like 6,000 years is really hard to make
like this is like a $30 bottle and it
should be because what they do is they
scrape off all of the fruit from these
trees and then within like a day they
have to capture it all and then go press
it and then spin it around get the oil
out and then they have to like quickly
bottle it and store it in like a cold
dark place and then like ship it in this
really delicate way it's incredibly
expensive and it's incredibly resource
intensive and bunch of Studies have come
out over the years where they go and
they test all of the olive oil on the
shelves and they find that like most of
this olive oil is not actually extra
virgin olive oil it's not the good stuff
so I think